- Tuesday thoughts,
as I go up the escalator,
get this lighting right.
I just can't believe how many
of you don't realize you're fundamentally
in charge.
You're completely and utterly in charge.
People dwelling and thinking other people
are controlling their lives.
It's fucking excuses to not do.
You are 100% in charge and in control
of your circumstance.
You just gotta break
the vortex
if you're not happy.
You just gotta break the game you're in.
You gotta break the box
that you're stuck in.
You've gotta break shit.
'Cause you're in control.
Nobody else.
If you see something
we're doing, you should
email us and be like, "Hey,
why did D-Rock do that?
"Why'd you make it Alexa briefing."
You can feel super
comfortable in that all.
- [Alexa] February 5th and the Super Bowl,
the Falcons lost to the Patriots.
- Out of all the things, Alexa?
(laughing)
Alexa, turn off.
I mean, Jesus fucking Christ.
I have to agree deeply on two fronts.
("Waves" by Anthony Russo)
♫ Lemme get lost for a second
- Do I believe in the entrepreneur?
Two, do I believe in the thesis?
And I've learned recently
that I can't waver.
I need to be 100 on both,
that's when I've won,
and anytime I haven't
been 100 on both, I've lost.
My intuition, entreintuition,
is there's not a lot
of people that know me,
care about me, and that
we know, that are more
wired into India.
So I'd really like you two
to build a relationship.
I'd like to go to India
in...
Late February, okay.
Cool.
- Okay, we're good.
Thanks so much for your time Gary.
- Such a pleasure meeting you, man.
I really enjoyed it.
♫ Tell me you'll wave (mumbles)
♫ Tell me you'll wave
- What's goin' on, man?
- Hi man, how ya been?
- Long time.
- Yeah man, you been well?
- Yeah, of course.
- Good to see ya.
- This is Derin.
- Derin, my pleasure.
Strategy number one is sheer will.
The most important part of the strategy
is how fun is it to lay in bed from
11:30 PM to two in the morning,
and type shit by yourself,
one by one, and I'm very rare super phone,
I mean, I looked at it two years ago now,
I'm about to play with
it as well, a little bit.
Like, strategy's super simple.
Here's the punchline.
I wrote about it in
2011, it's real simple.
I think you should say hello
to every single fuckin'
person who's ever listened
to your song lyrics.
Last time looking at the 800,000,
it's hard.
You know, it's really wild.
I just genuinely think it's about depth
and width, and everybody
only thinks about width.
So when I have somebody DM me and be like,
"You're the fuckin' best!"
When I fuckin', a lot of times I heart it,
they lose their mind.
Sometimes I'm in the mood,
I'm like, thanks Karen.
In video reply, which
takes like four seconds
that I don't have, right?
Then she fuckin', is a fan for life.
("All Alright" by Kyle)
♫ Even if my girlfriend has a baby
♫ Even if my guy don't really pay me
♫ Even if my guy don't ever save me
- Intuitively.
And was like it'll fun for him come
and spend 20 minutes and educate me,
I'm like, Gary, no, no,
the reason I think YouTube
is good, or why I think Nielson's has a,
like, the things that
I want to get to next,
I'm very, as you can tell, hands off.
I like people calibrating, auditing.
I don't like putting them into my vision.
- [Guy] Sure.
- I like them to be independent thinkers
and taste and learn.
(mumbling)
I mean, the best part
is, we can't show shit,
but in like 10 years we'll show it all,
and it'll bring people so much value.
♫ Even if my guy don't ever save me
♫ I won't eva waste my time complaining
♫ Audi five is all I ride
♫ No need to whine
♫ It's all alright
♫ If your phone just die
♫ You can borrow mine
- A lotta people ask, 'cause like,
when they're tryin to network,
and they're a teenager,
what do you say, now
that you live in a world
where you can access social media through
Facebook groups, do you target that,
or do you say try to
go to as many in person
meetups as possible?
- Oh, I would use
technology, I mean, fuck.
Between the fact that now
technology is so respected
that a 39 year old, a 52
year old, a 70 year old,
will actually respect you,
like when I was a kid,
there's no 19 year old
that had any respect about
business from anybody
on Earth, period, ever, anytime, ever.
So, for entrepreneurs
today, they have such
an incredible situation, one,
they have the luxury that somebody might
think you get it, 'cause
everyone's looking
for their Mark Zuckerberg, and number two,
you can get to anybody.
What the fuck are we doing here?
- Yeah.
- Like, right?
- If your FaceTiming--
- But this is not
happening 20 years ago,
you just wouldn't have
been able to get to me.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's just
not how the world worked,
so no, I think everybody
should use, whether
you're 19 or 91, everybody
should use technology
as a gateway drug to scale, to meet,
I think every single person that is an
entrepreneur under 20, that
wants to be successful,
should hit their DM limit
everyday, DM-ing entrepreneurs
or people that they're
interested in, saying,
"I'd love to meet you,
what can I do for you?"
- Yeah.
("They" by Blake)
- My biggest advice to young people
is to not try to convince
people to take them serious.
I think the best thing
you could do is when
you're having that conversation, is tell
them that, "If you don't
wanna work with me,
"you don't have to work with me."
- [Boy] Yeah, true.
- Saying no, for the other person,
a lot of times, it's the quickest way
for the other person to say yes.
- [Boy] Yeah, that's true.
("They" by Blake)
♫ Try to make honest money in abundance
♫ Talking 'bout 20's and 50's and 100's
♫ I make hit after hit
I know that it's comin'
♫ I better trickster, with the way I been
♫ Runnin' shit, know that I'm destined
♫ For greatness, everyone always be hatin'
♫ Everyone wanna be famous
♫ Nobody wanna be hated
♫ I'm sick and tired of seein' these faces
♫ But nobody's sayin' shit
♫ I been the one that's been playin' shit
♫ Star but I'm famous and she sit behind
♫ Where all of them players sit
♫ Yeah but you know that I'm makin' it
♫ Why no one sayin' shit
♫ Why do I feel like I'm fakin' it
♫ Don't even know why the
fuck I'm debatin' this
♫ This is all a part of the show
♫ Tell me it is I don't know
♫ They don't really know
♫ This is what you came for
♫ This is what you paid for
♫ They don't really know
♫ What the fuck you say for
♫ This is what you paid for
- There's so much that's happening
from serendipity of learning,
I do think that leaders
take way too much onus
on lemme fabricate these learnings
when we are moving fast.
Nobody even realizes what they're learning
here until they're almost out of it,
'cause we're sucked in a vortex,
people don't realize,
we're at the forefront
in such a meaningful way.
♫ They don't really know
♫ This is what you came for
(commotion of restaurant)
- Bye, thank you!
I don't think that I'm a predictor,
I think I'm a fast mover,
and so I don't predict, I have intuitive
understanding of consumer behavior.
And that I watch what people are doing and
I move quickly on it.
In a world where it's only 24 hours,
and everybody has,
one of the reasons I will
break out in this era,
on one on one marketing,
is I have more energy
than everybody else.
You know, it's something,
it's why I don't get
so gassed on myself, like
I have natural energy,
I can go.
Hard.
Forever.
Like you know, and so I think that's
not replicatable for some people.
People take naps, people
need eight hours sleep,
people get tired,
but I'm so grateful and I'm so hungry
that I just makes me go through,
so I think one of the
things is, the biggest thing
is if you're, you think about it in steps.
If you're on that next
step now these guys,
you know, and then you'll have some sort
of, you'll probably put
out some song that will
be the song, that takes
it to the next level.
It's about being has
hungry, when you're getting
300,000 racks for the show,
and it's super hard.
And as one of the people who's been able
to get hungrier as he's
gotten richer and more
successful, it's obvious to me, watching
all my other homies fall off when they get
to that place.
So what's really
interesting, is I don't know
if I can, it's not about so many tactics,
it's about having a
religious conversation.
Like, there's some
things in people's lives
that they will never do.
I think the question
becomes what are your lines
in the sand.
You know, start really
digging deep into them.
It's about self awareness.
It's about how much you appreciate it,
how hungry are you at it,
what comes natural, what doesn't,
it's the framework.
For me, I will never, line in the sand,
I will never ever believe in my own shit.
I'm in 11:22 PM.
Just another grinding day.
Super hustle.
Lotsa results, lotsa meetings.
Today was a fast paced day.
Like, very few days have
happened in the last year
where I haven't posted
anything on Instagram all day.
That's when you know I don't
even have a flippin' second.
Just really enjoying the process.
I'm obsessed with it,
I love it.
I enjoy it.
And I hope you do too.
There's just nothing like it.
When you're in that zone.
(belching) Excuse me.
When you're in that perfect zone.
("All Alright" by Kyle)
♫ Even if my girlfriend has a baby
♫ Even if my guy don't really pay me
♫ Even if my guy don't eva save me
♫ I won't eva waste my time complaining
♫ It's all alright